hello and welcome to the chicky science
show where in this video we're going to
talk about
beam therapeutics and their latest
announcement
regarding their new cell therapy for
t-cell acute lymphoblastic leukemia
by using base edited chimeric antigen
receptor t
cells whereby they were able to
simultaneously edit four different genes
within the t
cells and the name of this therapy is
beam 2a1
so as we'll see in this video the
company have some pretty promising
preclinical data for beam 201 and so are
deciding to advance
beam 201 as a development candidate for
the treatment of t-cell acute
lymphoblastic leukemia
so in this video firstly i'll just
introduce you to beam therapeutics
and then we'll talk about this latest
announcement telling you how
they've been able to do this and achieve
96 to 99
on target editing by using base editing
to simultaneously edit four genes
and then we'll look at why in particular
they needed to edit so many different
genes
and then lastly we'll just look at where
they're at and kind of summarize
everything together
so firstly then what is beam
therapeutics well
beam therapeutics is a biotechnology
company developing precision genetic
medicines
through the use of base editing so i'll
mention
shortly what base editing actually is
but the company itself was founded in
2017
by david leo and feng sang amongst
others
and they're currently trying to use face
editing approaches
to be able to treat a variety of
different diseases such as different
cancers
as we'll see in this video but also
potentially for liver diseases
and for sickle cell diseases as well so
next then what actually is base editing
well pretty much is what it says it
edits spaces
so to be a bit more clear the human
genome has four types of bases that can
be found in dna
adenine cytosine guanine and thymine
adenine has with thymine and cytosine
pairs of guanine
so a with t and c with g and the
sequences of these bases are really
important for expression of different
genes
within the cell and mutations in
different genes
that alter the sequence can result in
disease
so bottom line the sequence of faces is
really important for correct
gene expression so currently there are
two main
base editors there are cytosine base
editors
whereby the base can be changed from
cytosine to thymine
and there are adenine-based editors
whereby the bases can be changed from
adenine to guanine
so i'm going to tell you about cytosine
base editors because it's the one that's
used in beam 2a1
so although base editing doesn't really
sound like crispr cast 9
gene editing it still very much depends
on the crispr cast 9 components
to be able to target specific dna sites
of interest
so a cytosine based editor firstly
consists of cast 9
that is an rna guided dna nuclease
and a nuclease referring to something
that can cut dna
and so the major difference between base
editing and crispr
cast 9 gene editing is that class 9 in
its normal functioning state
induces a double-stranded break into dna
however
base editing works by only inducing a
single stranded break into the sites
where you want an edit to occur so the
cast 9 is there to help target
the cytosine base editor but how do you
actually go from cytosine
to thymine well the cas9 is fused to a
cytodine d-aminase
and what this does is it removes an
amine group from
cytosine and so what this actually does
is convert cytosine into uracil
which in an rna form is actually read as
thymine
so currently we've gone from a guanine
cytosine pairing to a guanine
uracil pairing but as i said earlier c
pairs of g
and a pairs with t or u in this case
so how do we now go from u to g
to u to a well this is the challenging
part because uracil isn't supposed to be
in dna
and so there's an enzyme within the cell
known as uracil dna glycosylase that
will get rid of that uracil and
convert it back into cytosine restoring
the original base pairing
so to circumvent this the cytosine base
editor is
also fused to monomers of uracil
glycosylase inhibitor
and so this helps to inhibit the
activity of uracil glycosylase
and so it prevents the uracil from being
removed
and so the way that you can then go from
a uracil to guanine base pad to a uracil
to adenine base pair
occurs during dna replication where you
generate a new dna sequence
and whilst in theory this editing would
be a 50 50 chance
as to whether the uracil or the guanine
would would remain
this ratio can be biased by nicking the
strand that contains the guanine
such that the strand that contains the
uracil is
kept instead and you end up going from c
to g
to u or now thymine to adenine
and so this is the reason why the cast
nine only knicks one strand
instead of having a cast nine that
doesn't actually nick either of the
strands
so irrespective of whether or not you
followed any of what i just said
and apologies if you didn't i hope you
can at least understand
how challenging base editing is and then
how remarkable it is
that these preliminary results from beam
therapeutics
seem to show simultaneous edits of four
different dna locations
at the same time so what is beam 201
then
what were they trying to do with it well
beam 201
is a developmental candidate that is
generated
using base editing to be able to treat t
cell acute lymphoblastic leukemia
and so this is a cancer of t cells that
can be found in your blood
and one way this cancer can be treated
is through the use of
cardi therapy and this is a type of
therapy whereby
they can reprogram t cells to attack the
cancerous t cells so some t on t
cell crime so the premise behind car t
cell therapy is that you can take t
cells from the patients
and reprogram them in a manner such that
they express
this chimeric antigen receptor which is
where the car
of cardi therapy comes from and this
receptor
has been designed such that it can
recognize
targets on the cancerous t cells and
kill them
and so one reason why they take t-cells
from the patient
is that when they put the reprogrammed
t-cells back into the patient
there isn't an immune response to the
foreign
cells because the cells originally came
from the patient
however card t cell therapy is quite
expensive and it takes time to
you know extract the t cells and to do
the reprogramming
and so what beam therapeutics were
trying to do was to develop some car t
cells that could be
universally compatible and so to do that
they needed to take some
t cells from a healthy donor and not
only insert
the car t-cell receptor that is the
premise behind the car t
cell therapy but also to edit the t
cells
such that they could be compatible and
also to improve the efficacy of these
modified t cells in killing the
cancerous
t cells of the patients so the part that
doesn't require base editing
is the addition of this chimeric antigen
receptor
and the receptor that they designed it
targets the antigen cd7
that's found on the cancerous t cells
and this can be added to the cells
through electrophile transduction and so
given that these t
cells are going to be targeting
cancerous t cells that express
cd7 it'd be pretty good for the
modified t-cells to also to not be
expressing
cd7 otherwise you could end up with the
modified t-cells attacking each other
and what happens then is that this these
nice nice modified
t-cells get depleted over time by their
own actions
a base editing can be used to silence
the expression of cd7
in the modified t-cells in addition
there were three other genes that they
wanted to silence
this includes the gene that encodes
endogenous t
cell receptor which enables the beam 201
cells
to prevent host rejection another gene
was cd52
which they wanted to silence to help
prevent rejection of the beam 201 cells
when the patients are lympho-depleted as
they receive
cells from a healthy donor and the last
gene to be silenced
is pd1 and the rationale behind this
is that a lot of the cancerous t cells
in the patients
express pdl1's ligands pdl1
and this pdl-1 pd-1 interaction
suppresses the activity of t cells and
so by depleting pd-1
they can prevent the potential
inhibition of the t cells that they're
trying to add to the patients
and so to summarize the aim of the
different edits
are to make beam 201 cells that are
unable to cause
graft versus host disease where the body
recognizes the cells as foreign
resistance the fractal side which is
what i was talking about
with the t cells the modified t cells
attacking each other
and also resistant to immunosuppression
and to
basically to prevent host rejection and
to make the cells
universal and so as you can see in this
figure here
the preclinical data that's come from
beam therapeutics
shows that they have simultaneous base
editing of these four different gene
loci
by using the cytosine base editor in
primary human t cells
and the efficiency they were getting is
around 96 to 99
on target editing which is pretty
impressive
and the t t-cells seem pretty amenable
to the base editing process
since their grave remains pretty similar
to how it was before the editing
and also during the editing there was
minimal impact on the p53 pathway
which as we were on a p-53 is my
favorite racing
and is a stress activated protein and so
this is a good sign
that the base editing process wasn't
stressful
or inducing any particular damage within
the cells
and then lastly in this preclinical work
they've also characterized the efficacy
of beam 201
in the tumor mouse model and so quite
remarkably as you can see in this figure
here
it shows a potent in vivo tumor
clearance
of the tumor in these mice and it's also
kind of a dose-dependent
manner whereby you see the more cells
that are given to the mice
the greater the clearance compared to
the control
so all of this is very promising
pre-clinical data
and so as i mentioned somewhere in the
beginning the company are now going to
progress
beam 2a1 towards clinical development
and to their knowledge and to my
knowledge as well this will be the first
cell therapy that has four simultaneous
genetic edits
which basically demonstrates the power
of multiplex based editing technology
and so for me i think that's pretty
pretty cool and so yeah it'll be
exciting to see
how this therapy progresses and i'll be
sure to try and keep a track on it
so hopefully you've learned something in
this video where we've gone all about
that base
and as always thanks for listening